The Joe Rogan Experience is coming back
to YouTube after signing a new deal with
Spotify that no longer makes a podcast
exclusive to their platform this is the
second contract Joe has signed with
Spotify and early reports claimed the
New Deal will be worth $250 million
putting Joe over the half billion Mark
in Spotify deals alone under the new
contract Spotify will handle
distribution and AD sales for the
podcast and Rogan will receive a
guaranteed minimum fee from Spotify as
well as a cut of advertising Revenue JRE
has been on top of the podcast world for
a long time now averaging 190 million
audio downloads per month to go along
with a YouTube channel full of 16
million subscribers who will all be
happy to hear